i used to work for precog
and the shirt and i currently work for
rich relevance
so i'm excited to be here today to talk
to you about category theory
so uh here's a brief outline of the talk
first we'll talk about git history as a
category
we'll define a terminal and initial
object which are both categorical
constructs
in terms of a git history then we'll
look at both polymorphism and
currying as two different examples of a
natural transformation
and then we'll at the end look at uh
maybe five might really fall between two
and three but we'll look at an example
of a contravariant
functor so
onwards get get chemistry sir git commit
history so
most of you are probably familiar with
um with
version management systems so you can
think about commit history as a dag or a
directed ace
directed acyclic graph so directed graph
means
we have these arrows and the nodes know
about their parent but in this case not
their child
so you can imagine someone makes a
commit a and then we we have a branch
here
someone else makes a commitment g and
they commit h
and then on the other branch we may
commit b and then well down here e would
be an example of a merge commit where we
would have merged
these two these two branches together
so just a bit of a bit of scala here
details aren't super important but the
idea is an individual commit will know
about its parent
a merge commit will know about its left
parent and its right parent
and then we'll have this notion of a
first commit which is the first commit
you'd make and it won't have a
won't have a parent above it so these
are the
the case classes we'll need to to
construct ourselves a
directed basic graph so we'll start out
with our first commit
and then two different people will make
a make individual commits that are both
parented off of that that original first
commit
and then you can go ahead and get and
merge that merge those two
those two branches back together and get
that's when git automatically creates
this merge commit for you okay so we all
have in our heads now this idea of this
this graph that git always has behind
the scenes
so what i want to do now is create a
category out of this
out of this graph so we need three
things in order to create a category
first off we need a collection of
objects these objects can be
anything you want in our case the
objects are going to be the nodes in our
graph of commits
so we'll use the simple example we have
four nodes in our graph
and these four nodes will be will be our
objects
there's something very small and
tractable to start with
okay so i said we need three things the
second thing we need
are a set of morphisms which are
sometimes called arrows in the
literature
and these morphisms or arrows are a way
to get you from
one object to another but they can be
very vague notions they don't have to be
functions or anything
anything more sort of anything that
actually
transforms one object to another they
just need to have a way to relate
two different objects in your category
together so
if you look at our the first and left
commit here
so first commit doesn't know about the
left commit so we'll have that
this set of of the setomorphisms would
be empty there
but the merge and first commits well if
you start at the merge commit you can
make your way up to the first commit so
so there is some relation there we'll
call it the less than or equal relation
and then another commit will i say
between every two objects we need a set
of morphism so between the left object
and itself for example the left object
is less than or equal to itself since it
is itself so there'll be there'll be a
morphism in that
um in that set as well so you can see in
this in this
in this category here each set of
morphisms for every pair of objects
either going to be empty
or have just one morphism in it because
either an object is less than another
meaning you can
you can start for that lesser one and
move to the move to the other parent
or the two objects have no relations
so so so far we have our objects which
are the commits we have the morphisms
which is the sense of
reachability now what we need to create
our category is a way to compose
morphisms together
so we'll compose morphisms
basically by saying well if merge knows
about left
and left knows about first then we can
compose those two morphisms so
this merge commit has first as a sort of
superparent
and that's how we'll define um the fine
composition of morphisms in this
category
and a couple of the side notes at the
bottom uh just for for the sake of
thoroughness
uh this these composition composition of
morphisms has to be associative meaning
doesn't matter where you put the
parentheses and there also has to be an
identity morphism for every object
so those two rules um come into play
when you're when you're proving things
in category theory
without those two rules you'll be able
to prove a whole lot less and categories
honestly wouldn't be very
would be very meaningful so this is our
first example of a
of a category
so i said in the outline we would talk
about terminal and initial
objects so by definition if for every
object
x the set so i'll say what hom f x
is in a second if that set has size one
you have an initial object so
the set harm f x would be the set of
morphisms
from f to x and if for every single
object in your graph that set has one
has size one then that object is an
initial object so if you look at the
structure here
if you look at consider object object f
down at the bottom
well f is less than every single object
in this category so f is an initial
initial object
meaning that all objects are reachable
from our object
f so this gives you a way
this gives you a way if you're thinking
about your git history say
well you can you can now think about
your git history and ask yourself the
question okay does this
tree structure this graph structure i
have here have an initial object or not
and then analogously we have terminal
objects so the analogous definition is
for every object x the set of morphisms
from x
to a since it's terminal has size one so
this is the
sort of the flip side this means that
that all objects can reach up to a so in
this in this graph in this example um
object a would be a terminal object
because every object is a
is a child of it
so so we're going to switch gears
actually now one more slide then we'll
switch gears terminal and initial
objects so
question is is a terminal or initial
object guaranteed to exist
answer is no here's an example of a of a
dag that has neither a terminal nor an
initial object so
it is a valid question to consider some
kind of dag and ask yourself okay is
there a terminal object or is there
is there an initial object
okay so now switching gears so this
first category i gave you
had assuming we have a finite graph some
finite number of
finite number of nodes in it and the
finite number of more morphism is
between those nodes
but we can also instead of thinking
about an individual graph as a category
we can think we can think about
the category of all graphs so suddenly
instead of the objects being the
individual nodes in the graph
the objects are going to be the graphs
themselves so any graph itself
including its nodes and the relations
between those nodes
that is going to be an object in a
category
and the morphisms are going to be ways
we can transform one graph
into another graph so i say structure
preserving graph homomorphism so
structure preserving that's that's the
important part that's what a graph
homomorphism means
it means that it's structure preserving
so what that what that means is that
adjacent nodes are going to map to
adjacent nodes this is a property that
lets a
lots of graph morphism be meaningful
because if you just map everything every
which way then
then there's really no you're not
preserving anything
from the original graph so if you look
at
the example down here we have two graphs
graph one on the left
and graph two on the right just has
these two nodes here
so if you see well on graph two sorry
excuse me on graph one adjacent node
mapped to adjacent node so a and b
are an adjacent so they'll map to q and
x so they're still adjacent
and the same for for all the other nodes
so we're preserving some of the
structure of graph one as we map it over
to
to graph two and then you can imagine
we also need to be able to compose graph
a compose graph homomorphism so you can
imagine a third graph over here
third graph to the right of those two
where we first do one
sort of cetamorphisms and then do the
next do the next graph homomorphism
okay so we have a couple examples of
categories now
so in order to sort of talk about some
more more deep
topics in category theory uh we also
need to talk about functors
because functors are what lets us move
from one category to another they'll
transform one category into another
category so suddenly we have
relationships between categories and not
these standalone things
so that's why functors are so important
because they let us relate categories to
one another and then talk about
what those relations are like so
functors are morphing morphisms between
categories the first example here
something called a forgetful functor
so imagine we have the category of all
graphs so capital graph there is the
category of all graphs for the objects
or
our entire graphs themselves we can
essentially forget the structure
of these graphs and map them to the
category set we're in the category set
the objects or
our sets and the morphisms would be
functions from one set to another set
so take a peek ahead here okay
so um we know that a functor needs to
map the objects
but a functor also needs to map the
morphisms in a category because the
category isn't just objects it's also
the morphisms those are equally as
important and we shouldn't we shouldn't
forget them
so if we have some graph homomorphisms
here well the graph homomorphism says
where to map the objects and where to
map the relations between them
well suddenly if we're dropping those
relations we don't need to worry about
mapping anymore mapping them anymore
because they don't exist
so in order to get a new function from
our new function and set
we'll just we'll just see where that
graph homomorphism took the objects
and used that as our new function and
we'll forget about the morphisms because
we dropped them we forgot them so
that's a good first example of a functor
because i think it's um it's relatively
intuitive
okay so now we're going to look at some
other examples of
of functors in scala so you can consider
um the option functor
so in scala an option is either a sum or
a none where some is some
of something you have nothing so the
option type is parametrized and some
scala type i mean you can have an option
of a or an option of b
or you can have an option of integer or
string or some
some other type that you made yourself
and what option does is well
we have an option it gives us a way to
convert from some some instance of a
type a
to an instance of a type option of a so
i mean this
little optionalized function just so you
can see a bit of code here we have an a
you can wrap it in a sum and suddenly we
have an option of a
so so let's let's tie this back to
category theory for a minute here
so we can have a category of scala types
where the objects in this category are
going to be the types
and the morphisms in the category are
going to be functions from
type to type so we can say we can think
of option as a functor
on the category of scala types since
it's taking one cat since it's taking um
since it's taking one category to
another so
let's see
okay so the option functor so not only
is it transforming more physics
excuse me not not only is it
transforming objects
from the category of scala types to
itself but it's also transforming
morphisms
so okay so the important thing i should
say here is option is
option is going from this category the
category of scala
types to that same category so that's a
that's an example of an endo function
we're not actually switching categories
here
where we're staying within the same
category so
so option has a way to give us objects
in
the in the category of scala types to
other objects in that same category but
we also need to transform the morphisms
so here's a function here if you look
the signature is really what's important
if you have some function that takes you
from type a to b
and you're given an option of a then you
can get out an option of b
so so this is an important notion
because this gives us a way to map
this f is this morphism here f
isomorphism from
ephesumorphism in the category of scala
and it's mapping some type
a to some type b and we have a way to
sort of lift that up into option
so in our picture here imagine we have
some function
foo give it an a get out of b we're
wrapping that an option so now we have a
way to go from option of a
to option of b well let's think of some
other examples list is a
is a simple one here so the exact same
say we have the exact same situation for
list where we can have a list of a
and have some function foo so we have a
way to get from a to b
start with some list of a and we can we
can give ourselves um
a list of b so we have something here
that's starting to um
it's starting to look like a like a
diagram
so what if we could what if we could
further connect this diagram
and make it complete somehow if i make
it complete what i really mean is
are there any kind of arrows we can draw
between
between option and list and if so what
would that what would that arrow look
like and what would it mean that we can
draw an arrow there
what are we really doing by drawing
these arrows
so i'll propose sort of one of the most
obvious arrows that you could draw
from option to list and we can talk
about uh talk about what that means
so
so this will bring us into a parametric
polymorphism
so a polymorphic function in general is
going to be a function that can
that can operate on on some type that
that isn't defined when you write the
method signature
so if you look at our example here i
called it optilist
parametrized in some type a where a
could be whatever you want it to be when
you actually
um when you actually call this function
so it's going to take an option of a
and give this out a list of a it'll do
what you think it might do if you have
if you have an a then it'll give you a
singleton list with that element
if you have nothing then it's going to
give you an empty list because you can
put anything in your list because you
don't have anything
so this is a really basic way to get us
to get us from an option of a to a list
of a or similarly from option to b to a
list of b because option of a and option
of b are
i mean when a and b are just types i'm
throwing around those are the same thing
so a couple examples here so
we can call our list on sum of four and
get a list of four or call it on some of
the string foobar whenever you have a
list of string
or if you call it on on a none then
you'll get an empty list of integers
since i chose to parametrize it on into
there
so so we have here is a way
a way to get us from an option of some
some nebulous type to a list of that
same type
bam we'll put those put those arrows in
there okay so suddenly we have this
complete diagram it feels
you know it feels complete we could we
could trace it going across the top and
down
or we could trace it down into the
bottom in both ways we start out with an
option of a
and get to a list of b but we have two
different ways to get there and
well they could be different just
because we started with an option of a
and go down to a list of b
going this top way or start out with an
option of a and go down to a list of b
using this this bottom root doesn't mean
it's the same list of b or we're
actually doing the same
thing so what's really important is that
that we can convince ourselves that
actually
regardless of which way we traverse this
diagram if you imagine
it's called diagram chasing when you
start with an element sort of map it
over
or map it down and over you want to
really convince yourself that
that that whichever way you go you're
going to get the same thing and we'll
talk about what that what that actually
means in terms of option and list
so the vocabulary the word commute means
that
regardless of which way you you chase an
element through the diagram
you'll get the same result that's what
commute means here
so some vocabulary we have
polymorphism here so option of t or
polymorphism so that means our
polymorphism
is represented by these vertical these
vertical arrows here
so this function optilist which we saw
previously
it's the exact same function for type a
and for type b because it's parametrized
on it so
we have the exact same thing that gets
us from the option
row at the top down to this list
this list row at the bottom
so so what we can show is if you were to
work out the details you can take some
some element
some element from option of a you can
use our map function that we defined
earlier
and then map it down to a list of b and
if you do the same thing
going the other direction you can
convince yourself in a couple lines that
this diagram really does commute
and it actually doesn't matter if you
map your option
and then use your polymorphism or if you
use your polymorphism
and then map it over this is really
really important because if we just had
polymorphisms
but we didn't have this property then
and then we'd have to really be careful
about what we did with them because
if we if we somehow changed changed what
we had in our hands before using the
polymorphism or
perform the polymorphism and change it
after we could end up with different
results
which would be really really horrible so
this
we can convince ourselves that we're not
not ending up with different results
so so this whole thing here
this whole thing is is describing a
natural transformation
so specifically the natural
transformation part of this whole
part of this whole madness is this
octolist function this polymorphism that
we defined
this is our natural transformation and
okay so it's transformation means
transforming what to what
well a natural transformation is a way
to transform
one functor which is the option function
we have here
down to this other functor which is the
list function we have here
so we have this whole option functor at
the top transforming it with our natural
transformation and ending up with a
with a second functor down below
so so here's a
i have a little copy of the diagrams to
keep it in your mind there but
not meant to be read so so here's just
the formal definition of what a natural
transformation means so for every single
object
x we have which would be in this case
for every type we have integer or string
we have this natural transformation
which is taking
option of integer to list of integer
option of string to list of string
we can define those functions which in
our case is this polymorphism
we're going to find out such that for
any morphism we pick from x to y
the diagram commutes so it's really
quite a strong statement it's saying
that
we can fix these polymorphisms and then
no matter what other morphism from x to
y we choose
it doesn't matter what we choose once we
fix these two polymorphisms
if we choose the right ones then then
the diagram is going to be commuting
so we're going to jump to a second
look at a second example of of a natural
transformation here so
currying also known as shown
fingalization i like that a little
better than
occurring it was named after someone
named sean finkel who actually did a lot
more of the
rudimentary work and in developing the
theory of what we now call currying and
did
curry himself so i will talk about shown
fincalization next
so uh just to so
just to get the the definitions out
there you see we have this first
uncured function which will take two
integers and return an integer
or we can have a curried function which
instead of returning an integer will
return you another function
that takes an integer and gets you
another integer so i think the um
the signatures and the bottom two lines
of the of the code block are sort of
almost more and forward
for informative than than above because
you can see the uncured version you feed
it a two and a three where the curried
version you could feed it a two
once you fed it to two you're left with
a function from individual integers and
you could feed it something else but
but what's really integrated about
curing is that you don't have to feed it
that second three
you can just do curative two and then
you have a function from end to end
and you could pass that on to some other
function which requires an intervent for
example
so so that's one reason that occurring
is
is nice so we'll see a few slides from
now that curing is going to provide us
another example of a natural
transformation before we get there we
need to do some more um
some more groundwork so keep this in
mind as we go through as we go through
the next bit
so okay it won't be it won't be obvious
immediately how this ties back to
to currying but we will we will get
there so hum
functors so i mentioned this notation
hom of
x y or hom of a b um a few minutes ago
so to put it into writing here since
we're going to be talking about it a
fair
bit hom of x y is going to be the set of
morphisms from object x to object y
and what's implicit here is in some
category c so object x and y are both
going to be objects in the same category
and hom x y are going to be all the
morphisms from one object
x to all the morphisms um
sorry it's going to be all the morphemes
from object x to object y
remember when we had a category we had
objects and for every pair of objects we
had a set of morphisms
that relates one to the other well this
is that set we have in our hand here
okay great so we have a set of
cenomorphisms for some category
so what i want to do is is turn this
into a functor
so you're going to see this underscore
notation here and that essentially means
we're removing the object there and
letting us
letting us be letting us replace it so
hom of underscore y is going to be a
functor
so so what that means remember a functor
is a way to get us from
a category to another category could be
the same category it could be a
different category but it's a
transformation of categories
so this hom underscore b is going to get
us from some category
to the category of sets so set
is really important because ham as we
said up here is a set of morphisms
so so suddenly we're going to be
thinking about this this set of
morphisms which itself could have come
from a category
we're going to be thinking of that set
as an element of a of a different
category of the category set which is
which is the category of all sets
of anything at all so in the sum
category
so the sum category needs to be the same
category that object
is to use this notation or this language
down here that object
that object b came from
okay so okay so we have a functor
going from category to category
so we know we have things in our
categories that are objects and we have
other things that are
uh morphisms in our category so we need
to think about our functor in terms of
both the objects and in terms of the
morphisms
we can't forget either so the object one
will be
a little simpler here so if we take our
our function here and we apply it to
this
this object a then we're going to get
out
hom of a b which is the set of all of
all morphisms from object a
to object b that's sort of intuitive and
feels like what it should be so now we
have a set
because remember we're in the category
set
okay so here's our set but now we need
some way to understand morphisms
on that set so amorphism on set is going
to be a way to get from one set to
another
to another set so we need to apply
our we need to apply
our our functor hum of underscore comma
b
we need to apply that to some morphism
in our category
remember we applied it to an object we
know what we get we're going to apply it
to some morphism
we'll call it f which is going to take
object p to object q
and what that should give us is a new
map in our new category which is
set and it should give us instead of
having amorphism from p to q
inside our sum category we should get
out a morphism
inside our set category and that
morphism is
that that last line on the slide there
so
if you take a look at that something
switched around
it's not a typo so
so we should well why did i switch that
like what you know what's going on
so let's uh let's take a look at that
and see
see if you agree with what i did and see
if it actually makes sense to you
okay so this first line here
we're taking home underscore b and we're
applying it to some morphism
x to y so here is just a little bit of
code
here's what this this could look like in
your code so
throwing that in there because remember
these are morphisms
yes maybe in some abstract land but
these are actually functions that you
use on a day-to-day basis because all
we're doing is talking about functions a
way to get from one place to another
place and these are things you use
you use every day so keeping us grounded
i threw just this little
little bit in there okay so for going
from x to y
well logically if you're just saying
well we're going from x to y so then we
should go from ham x
b to harm y because that's just you know
it's the same order and it's what
is what you would write down first if
you're trying to figure this out
so definitely logical
in quotes but let's see if it makes
sense so
what do we have in our hands here so we
have this morphism defined at the top
some function that give it an x we get
out of y and then
if you look at this signature here
so we say we start out with our x y and
then this hum x b means we have
some morphisms from x to b well that
means we have an x to y and we have an x
to b
and we somehow need a y to be
well if you have a way to get from x to
y and a way to get from x to b
we have no guarantee about inverses or
anything like that we simply
don't know if we can get a y to b in
many cases we can't we can't guarantee
that so
this is one reason why my types are
great because
the types are really forcing us to do
the right thing because there's simply
no way to compose
two morphisms of those signatures to
compose them together and get us
something of the type you'd actually
need
if we were to put x and y in the same
order that they were and up here
so the correct idea so
what happens if we switch them it feels
really weird and it still feels weird to
me even after i like sat down and
thought about this
it feels really weird that we're
switching them but the type signatures
make sense and the type signatures are
something that you really have to trust
in this case
so again we have our function f which
goes from x to y and now we're giving
ourselves
functions from y to b so suddenly we can
start to compose these two functions
together we can go from x to y
and then go again from y to b and that
gets us from x
ultimately to b which is what we need in
that signature so suddenly everything
lines up and
that's exactly what we're looking for so
so we have this idea of
of flipping suddenly we went from x to y
and now
in our in our result the functor is
going from y to x so the arrows
the arrows reverse themselves and the
word for this is contravariance
so you can say that the hom functor is
contravariant in its first parameter
remember we put the underscore and the
first parameter of hom there
so so that means if you think of it as a
function where you're
where that first parameter is is an
underscore there
then then your contravariant in that
first parameter
so as an exercise um exercise to the
listener you could
you could see for yourself that if you
had the hom of a comma underscore
functor
and that would be covariant meaning that
the arrow wouldn't flip when you went
out and
figured out what what morphems what
morphisms you had and how they
could actually compose together so this
is contravariant the
the duel is covariance
comic interlude happy co-valentine's day
it's like valentine's day but the arrows
go in the opposite direction
so you can remember this comic if
nothing else
okay so i promised you currying
let's see what we can let's see why so
basically i promised you currying then
we went off and talked about hom
functors so
i better you know tie these hum functors
back into back into currying
okay so let's think about the type
signature of currying what it
what it means here so if we're occurring
in some type a or i'm presuming types b
and c are defined elsewhere and fixed
then this first part here
we have a ham from a cross b to c so
this cross is is just a cross product
that means a tuple we have a tuple of
some element from a and some element of
b
and we're spitting out a c so that's the
that's what we're starting with and if
we want to curry a function of the
signature
means we're going to turn it into
something that looks like this and what
this means is
instead of giving me an a and a b and
then i give you a c you give me an a
and then i give you a way that if you
have a b you can get a c
so okay so i think i'm going to i'm
going to pop
out the pop out the a here and thrown
and
throw in an underscore and suddenly
what we have here is what we just saw
the hom functor which was hom underscore
comma
some object well now i have this extra
cross b in there but that's now it's not
a big deal we can handle that
so what i really have here is
a functor very similar to the ones we
saw previously
and then another functor similar to the
ones we saw
previously and what i'm telling you is
that what currying is
and it's occurring is a way to get you
from
this one functor to another functor
so we're somehow transforming functors
so remember functors transform
categories into another so each of these
individually
as a functor is going from one category
to another but suddenly
we're doing something bigger because
we're taking
functor and transforming it into another
functor so
it sounds familiar think back to the
polymorphism
stuff we had uh had earlier we saw that
the polymorphism was what we called a
natural transformation it was taking
that option functor
and bringing it down to that list
functor so we were we were
transforming one functor into another
functor so now we have these two
functors slightly funny looking with all
these homs and x's and underscores but
they're functors we've we've seen what
they are so
so let's sort of write out what we have
here so we have these two curry
functions parameterized on
q and y a way to get from this uncurried
type signature down here to the curry
type signature
and it'd be really great if we could
draw draw more arrows in here such that
we get a commuting diagram like we had
last time
so so simply why not and the answer is
well why not if you could we can
actually draw and draw these map arrows
here
and these the the signatures um are
going to be essentially analogous more
or less to the signatures we saw
before when we were mapping um like
option of eight option to be in list of
a list of b it's the general map idea
so you can you can sit down and convince
yourself that you can you can write
these map functions
and for every for every
uh morphism we have going from a y to a
q
and for any elements of this hom set
here
we could use this map function and get
something of this harm set here
so so let me read through what we have
here so this should look
exactly like this the option list
diagram we had earlier that other
natural transformation diagram
so what it means is for every object q
we have this natural transformation
such that for any morphism at all we
pick this diagram is going to commute
so what's really wonderful about this
and what's meaningful about this
is that is that when you're currying you
don't have to worry about
applying some other some other function
application before or after you curry
you could do your curing and then apply
the function or go the other way apply
your function and then curry
and you get the same result that's
something that you definitely take for
granted because if we got different
results here it would feel like
something's truly wrong with math or
science or something would feel wrong if
this weren't true but
but what we're saying here is it's
really good it is true and you can write
out these signatures um
you can write out these signatures and
really convince yourself of it
so let's see
so i chose um so i chose to sort of pop
out the parameter a
in my example we could also pop out
another parameter say c
and then we could have this different
functor which goes from a cross b to
blank and this other function hom
of a hom b blank um and that's perfectly
fine as well you can do an
you can do an analogous exercise with
that um a google term
for you just underscore cross b and hum
b underscore something called adjoint
functor so what we've been talking about
here are
essentially adjoint functors so that's
on there just so you could do
do your own research later on
so just i just want to recap just recap
the currying bit here
so we had something of this first
signature a cross b to c
then we have something given in a give
you a way to get me
a c if you also have a b so i just took
them out of the hom notation and wrote
them
maybe a little more familiarly here so
when we went in that diagram we went
from a cross b
down to the curried form but
you can also go the opposite direction
so isomorphism means that they're
actually equivalent
both directions so we could start with
the uncurried excuse me start with the
curried version
and unquery it if you wanted
um so we actually have an isomorphism
between those two between between those
two sets so it's a bit stronger than
what i had
originally originally presented
that's it questions